Let's use our order of operations to help us solve this problem. We should solve
this problem going from left to right following the hierarchy of the order of
operations. Parenthesis and brackets serve as containers, and this should be
evaluated before we do any operations onto them. Brackets are typically used
only if they have parenthesis inside them, but we evaluate them the same way. We
start at the very inside and they work a way out. I'm going to simplify this
negative of 5 squared. I know this 5 squared only goes with the power, so I have
25 or negative 25. Now, I simplify this parenthesis, and then I add negative 20
to 3. I lose my brackets because I no longer have parenthesis. I just have
negative 17, so I write that in parenthesis. I can't simplify this parenthesis
anymore, so now I should go back and do my order of operations. Let's look for
powers. I have powers here and here, so I should simplify these numbers. I want
to be very careful. I have the negative of 3 squared, and the negative of 2
squared. I only square the 3 and I only square the 2. So, I have negative 9,
negative 17, and negative 4. Adding the opposite is the same thing as
subtraction, that's why I can write negative 17. Finally, I can add all these
negative numbers up, and I'll get my final answer. And I get negative 30. You
can think of doing parentheses and brackets first. We don't include them in our
order of operations because, well, they're not actually operations. They're just
containers.